We're ok. Berthing yes. It's hard to go home birthing was another aspect of this vision.
I mean we were really looking at cradle to the grave. And.
So women were dissatisfied with the present with with the situation as it was then. They wanted to.
Birth the children in in a loving. Nonclinical. Atmosphere. They didn't want.
Birthing to be considered a case for hospitals. It was really. To be seen as a natural thing.
And in many cases there was no need for hospitals. I mean it was still recognize the hospital said the place.
Something went wrong. So. So home birthing became a very strong movement here.
Run by women who are having children and. Those women as the children grew up with their inner g.'s when.
Somewhere else were replaced by other women. And that's continued to this day. So that's birthing then. Education.
I think i mentioned earlier that. We started the community school.
People were really concerned with a vacation that children were being educated in the broad enough. You know.
Non ridge amended. More flexible way. And so we set up our own schools and. We also. Started to see the whole.
Of all the activities in the area as part of our education. And our children's education it was a sort of a.
A university of life. And so people would hold workshops and. People would visit. Each other's places.
To different crafts. We were probably a little. Earthier then. Than we are now. It was very much back to the land.
And while that's still a very strong element. Now.
There's a lot of diversification and a lot of other interests as well. So there was a dick ation.
The university of life in the field. Practical sort of learning. I've lost the thread.
What else can i tell you about the right to write. Ok. Ok. Yeah. So.
Another aspect of of the values was the way we live. What sort of. Houses we leave the.
You know how we did our gardens and. How we integrated outside but the inside so.
Because of economic circumstances as much as anything else those a whole range of.
You know they do have ideas that flowed into the building. The field of being. And people were very conscious of.
Passive solar design use of. Benign materials materials that were ecologically sound.
And used a lot of recycled materials things that. At that time. Very much undervalued. You know.
Buildings would get demolished and the. And the timber would get burned. So people put together houses.
Using a whole range of these different materials. People build houses that were open plen a lot of use of lofts.
Lots of verandas. Borrowing from traditional straight in country style. Lots of. Use of alternative energy.
And many of these houses were located on properties that were way off the grid.
So there's no power no water no services. So people began to. Uses a solar panels.
With battery banks for their twelve volt systems to park their lights and their sound systems
and so on solar hot water. They used wind power many of the properties were located in the foothills. Around the.
Mountain ranges are on the forested areas. And they became. In a sense the protectors of the forest.
Such as at the rainier anyway these properties were ideally suited for. Water park. Because there'd be streams.
Running out of these. Rain forests which. Never dried up. And so. If you put a. Pelton wheel into them.
You could harness. Hydropower. And so that they'd use that as their energy source. Such a variety.
You know there are pharaohs samin as they sling in forest. That sort of look somewhat like mushrooms they're organic.
And the years of. Stain them with. You know. Mosques and stuff and they. They blend in beautifully.
I mean i'm particularly keen about recycling. Cereals.
Often with in the case of timber the recycled materials better than anything you can buy all the best trees were cut.
Years ago. And the team has really good quality season. And very strong local hardwoods. Through figley strong. Then.
Then there's all the cabinet making the members. Which you can sell the jaw off. Fall and logs.
Red cedar for instance you can still fire. And red cedar lying around. That was cut. Years ago.
A favorite house very difficult to actually pick something out.
I haven't thought of it in those to him so that's why doesn't the doesn't come to me i'm sure there is one
but i i just can't think of it as a feat. Well. I mean there have been amazing. House building feats. In terms of.
Just getting things built. There's a little stone cottage. Tangible which is build on top of cliff.
And every stone and every piece of material. Was brought up by flying fox. That.
That was a real feat and it was built by a woman. A frail. Not for a i shouldn't call a frail but a slightly built.
Young woman build a. Pole frame construction on steep.
Relatively steep hillsides with poles that are seven or eight meters long. You know thought sort of three storey.
Split level. Construction. Amazing energy. To put these things up. And to have had the guts to stick with it next lee.
Get it built. Because most of these people have no previous. Building experience. They become they become very.
Multiskilled on the land. You know there's so much to do there are so many. Manual tasks you.
Very quickly to handle two thousand and. Improvise and. So there's been a lot of that. Yes.
Many great feats of building. Oh yes many of these building.
Well i mean there are buildings that on finish that were started eighteen years ago.
And growing i mean this is another aspect of this style of building it's. It's organic. It grows and it.
It fluctuates according to needs. You know the. The. It might start off with a single person who then becomes a couple.
And you know so there have to add extra space. And then. Children come along and more space.
And they discover more and more about their environment and their immediate surroundings so things.
Get modified and improved to take advantage of the northeast libris the winter sun. Those sort of things.
So many buildings. Gone for many years. I think very few are ever built full stop.
You can only do that with a brick veneer you can do that with the sort of buildings we're talking about.
Well you know i realize that. It's sort of. I realize that it's. Twenty years now since aquarius.
But that in itself is just the date. I mean. Things have been moving and changing all the time.
And will continue to do so the vision that we had in those early years in the seventy's.
I think in many ways has been fulfilled though. Not precisely as we thought.
You know things are always changing it's a state of flux of growth of learning and. I see the next twenty years.
As a continuation of that same process. But i see the acceleration. I actually don't think. Contrary to.
You might hear all sorts of things about nieman and one of the things is that. Nothing's happening here.
Well you know i have my thing around a lot of things happening in the sort of pulse of mean that i know there are a lot
of things going on in all sorts of directions. You know.
Alternative energy rainbow power companies going from strength to strength and.
You know the future is in no alternative energy. I know the mainstream is still hooked. To nonrenewable resources.
But it's having to confront. You know the difficulties that. That are facing those that are coming here and.
So people like the rainbow power company are becoming more and more relevant to the mainstream.
And so there are all these aspects of our lifestyle that are still developing. There has been no full stop.
Nothing has really been. Achieved. And therefore you can put aside. Everything is still continuing.
And growing and evolving. Well i don't know if you. That's appropriate to say because most of us.
In the beginning that. Beginning wave. Weren't teenagers. We were in fact. You know. Early twenty's on.
To late thirty's. And so a lot of us have. Have reached middle age when you know now. Getting long of tooth and.
But i hope not weary of life. And a lot of kids are grown up here and. While many of them. Leave name been.
They take away. The spirit of name. And the values and. The sort of aquarian. Values. And many of them come back.
Many of us middle aged ones also leave and go to other places.
And we hear of friends all over the place doing similar things throughout. What they were doing here but often.
Often in the mainstream people in government departments. You know various. Community organizations.
Basically still moving. In the same direction still looking for alternatives to the dominant paradigm.
Which is you know. Which is failing us. And and. So they're looking for alternatives.
The evidence of that failure is everywhere about us. And i think.
So i see nimbin as continuing to pursue these concerns. Environmental energy. Schooling. Thing. Recycling.
You know we've set up a recycling center in the village. With very concerned with.
Waste management in general are we going to keep evolving. Community structures. You know. Got a thriving. Artist.
Artistic community. Got the school of arts with the. Many many musicians. Many painters. Craftspeople.
All of those things are continuing to be developed. And i think as. As the the world economic and environmental crisis.
Becomes more apparent. So the mainstream will look more and more to places like nimbin. For the solutions.